something we do know about a vicious
spring snowstorm is winding down leaving
a terrible toll in the Northern Plains
and Upper Midwest one person was killed
in Colorado when a car slammed into a
snow plow and the blizzard buried some
areas under more than two feet of snow
the state of Minnesota is in a state of
emergency situation and the snow storm
is now weakening that is good news but
there are new fears that it could cause
potentially disastrous flooding Adriana
Diaz is in hard-hit Watertown South
Dakota
Adriana good morning good morning the
people of Watertown will have to dig out
of this today with all this snow drift
some are going to have trouble figuring
out which cars are theirs now the wind
has died down but the snow continues to
fall
many major roads remain closed and
thousands are still without power across
the region cars at big rigs were no
match for whiteout snow and powerful
wind gusts topping 60 miles per hour
neither was this Minnesota State Trooper
as he tried to direct traffic around a
jackknifed semi trailer the wintry blast
shook powerlines freezing some and
toppling others at one point nearly
seventy seven thousand homes and
businesses were without power we usually
don't get this in a problem
here in Watertown we met Ron lor as he
tried perhaps in vain to clear snow from
his yard it's almost not worth even
trying to clear the snow in this it
really is enough I'll get out for a
while today and come home and spend the
rest day at home not everyone had that
option with several interstates shut
down more than a hundred truck drivers
were stranded at this rest stop so
you're sleeping in your truck yes I am
and the blizzard is impacting far more
than traffic back old we're usually
farming out in the field down here
they're farming too but it's gonna be
now with all this extra snow it's gonna
be a month yet farmers here in cattle
country are scrambling to keep their
livestock alive when you get 10 12
inches or more on the ground it's just
tough to talk to work and make sure
they're alright farmers told us they had
to stay up all night in shifts checking
on their cattle especially all the baby
calves that are born this time of year
some are also worried about extreme
flooding what's all this snow belts
severe floods wiped out entire farms in
other parts of the region last month
major Adriana thank you